et pour en parler avec nous au mcs est
là gabla il est journaliste et blogueur
spécialiste de l'afrique
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors des années
maintenant que barkan et là l'opération
a même changé non mais reste la même
globalement quel bilan en faites-vous
et merci je pense que nous ferons un
bilan est correct mais payet laugier
étant donné que l'armée française s'est
réalisée au sahel ennemis serait une
dictature qui est notamment celle du
cade et donc en tout cas nous verrons un
bloc très triste plus pour les
populations africaines également pour
les démocrates africains qui ce matin
mais vite face à olivier vous des
façades éligibles dans les ciels qui
sont soutenus malheureusement par paris
et la halle aux houblons énormément que
le pénis et français s'est déplacé ce qu
on déménage coca de rencontrer débit et
puis et puis faire une tournée qui pour
nous vraiment n'est pas opportune n'est
pas productif pour ceux qui s'y battre
de manière vraiment démocratique dans
notre pays
on se parle il a dit il ya quelques mois
nous n'avons pas vocation à rester
éternellement et c'est le but de ce
genre d'opération à limiter petit à
petit le niveau de l'engagement de
l'armée
mais là avec tout ce qui se passe ces
attentats ça paraît compliqué et c'est
tout à fait compliqué c'est la force qui
a compliqué qui a complexifié que tu
malades de layton sur le terrain et n'a
pas entendu et l'a pas écouté et les
clues de coeur de la société les cui
decker effectivement des démocrates
c'est qu'ils ont proposé d'alternative
pour éviter ce qu'il a fourni sa liste
au sahel est là aujourd'hui
nous estimons que l'erythrée nepad n'est
pas n'est pas dans l'immédiat parce que
la france en tête elle souhaitait les
maintenances et se trouve dans un
terrain qui ne lui est pas totalement
acquis parce qu'il ya des contestations
un peu partout sauf à au niger au mali
et même au cas dans sa vie nous avons
déclaré que le prix nice n'a pas inscrit
dans son agenda y recevoir les la stv2
opposants démocrates
le population qui se bat mais vite la
face à une dictature qui est celle du 10
10 en tout cas la forme les cadres à
quelque chose que aujourd'hui il ya une
forte contestation de sa présence ou
littéraire donc nous allons continuer
effectivement
informé à dénoncer cette pratique vous
savez madame des voix parlementaire
française comme jean luc mélenchon à vis
d'une filière qui hier la présence du
ministre français
les gens vivent leur avait déjà appelé
au respect de dix ans parce qu'il estime
que la présence des troupes françaises
sur le terrain
un hôtel est il qu'il n'était
aujourd'hui on a un staff l'équipe et
nous déplorons cette attitude donc selon
vous la france doit se désengager a
militairement de cette bande
sahélo-sahélienne ça voudrait dire que
les armées nationales locales assureront
seulement la sécurité de cette zone est
ce qu'elles sont prêtes
est ce qu'elles en ont les moyens
matériels et humains et la question des
moyens matériels ayant opposé depuis
longtemps la foi elle-même n'a pas été
effectué mois dernier à pékin d'avoir
une arme redoutable pour lutter contre
lequel vous avez déjà en 2002 moi je
veux attirer l'attention au sénégal
j'avais attiré l'attention de l'union
africaine sur le fait qu'il nous faut
une année continental pour ne pas
dépendre de la france aujourd'hui
depuis huit ans on a constaté les échecs
ce n'est qu'il est mitterrand s'est
senti au sahel et les tutsis quitter les
grands centres de population n'en
peuvent plus du parce qu' il appartient
effectivement au dessus de france et de
tirer les leçons et d'écouté dites-moi
ce que nous disons c'est qui l'astuce
8/10 et élocution démocratique et les
africains n 10 parce que nous avons les
moyens effectivement dignité réaliser
ces coûteuses sauf qu'aujourd'hui on a
affaire à un danger très compliqué parce
qu'il ya des forces étrangères qui sont
sur le territoire africain au niger au
mali au tchad
malheureusement c'est insistant sur les
casques et la présence de la défense qui
parce qu'il ya pas d'être us ou 4 donc
en tout cas nous constatons que la
méfiance aux quatre vingts dignité au
pouvoir parce que depuis toujours le cas
ne l'a pas n'a pas un appel au pouvoir
donc nous devons cette attitude nous
n'allons pas accepter c'est vraiment une
armée étrangère
pourquoi la bande sahélo sahélienne et
est devenue une zone de connexion pour
les groupes terroristes mais uniquement
parce que de plus en tant que madame le
salaire a été abandonné parce qu'il n'ya
pas
des mots niant à lui et c'est la
population locale donc sa population
locale
abandonné par le pouvoir central que ça
soit le pouvoir de niamey les pouvoirs
des parcs où se sont retrouvés
effectivement être là poétiquement de la
fota qui effectivement cela faudrait une
coopération militaire française qui a
essayé de tout les noms des piqûres la
copa sanitaire française n'a pas su
tenir effectivement nos armées locales
n'a pas soutenu des démocrates et la
suite unis plutôt des dictatures et donc
sa hausse a ouvert les portes à toutes
nées des livres à l'avancé les ennemis
du tourisme et qu'aujourd'hui on
justifie une intervention militaire qui
n'est pas approprié et donc nous pensons
qu'il faudrait considérer toutes les
approches et toutes les analyses qui ont
été faites
de mon point de vue que ce soit à paris
que ce soit à bruxelles ou bien un
gagnant pour que nous essayons de nous
donner des moyens à des vestes à lutter
véritablement contre eux mais le fait
que la france continue à soutenir des
régimes qui sont elles populaire ça pose
problème au niveau international sur le
côté graphique à manier la langue et la
remercie d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
blogueur spécialiste de l'afrique
martienne